in this lesson you're going to learn the
basics of trigonometry we're gonna be
talking about the sine cosine and
tangent ratios as well as how to work
with the angles in a triangle to find
missing sides or to work with the sides
of a triangle to find missing angles
we're gonna be doing the sine inverse
cosine inverse tangent inverse as well
as talking about the angle of elevation
and angle of depression so let's dive
right in the first thing we want to talk
about is you know what exactly is
trigonometry well if you look closely at
the word trig refers to triangle and
metree refers to measurement like the
measurements in a triangle whether it's
the angles or the sides so the first
thing you want to talk about are the
trig ratios also refer to as the sine
cosine and tangent of an angle now when
we talk about a trig ratio ratio means
you're comparing two quantities and in
this case we're comparing two of the
side lengths in a triangle so when we
talk about the sine ratio we're talking
about the ratio of the opposite side
length divided by the hypotenuse if
we're talking about the cosine we're
talking about the ratio of the adjacent
side okay that's the aside that's next
to the angle divided by the hypotenuse
the one that's across from the right
angle and then the tangent ratio is the
ratio of the opposite side the one
across from the angle divided by the
adjacent side the one next to the angle
now you're probably saying Mario that's
a lot to remember and I completely agree
with you and that's why a lot of
students when they're learning
trigonometry the first thing they learn
is this acronym so Toa
and what exactly does that mean well it
means asks for sine is the ratio of the
opposite side divided by the hypotenuse
the cosine mm-hmm is the adjacent side
divided by the hypotenuse and the
tangent is the opposite side divided by
the adjacent side so if you can remember
Soh Toa and just remember it's the
second letter divided by the third
letter you'll have those ratios now
we're gonna do examples with all these
so you can get really good at it and the
first thing you want to understand
though before I jump in an example is
say if you have a little triangle like
this where it's a 30-degree angle and
you've got a right angle
and here you have a larger triangle that
has a 30 degree angle and this right
angle you probably learned in geometry
that when you have two angles that are
congruent to two angles the triangles
are what we call similar and what it is
is that one triangle is basically
proportionally larger than the other
triangle or they are proportionally
smaller and what happens is that if
you're let's say we're looking at the
sine of this angle sine is the opposite
side okay that went across divided by
the hypotenuse see how that ratio is 1
over to 1/2 whereas in this larger
triangle here the sine of 30 degrees is
the opposite side 3 divided by the
hypotenuse 6 well 3 divided by 6 is the
same as 1 divided by 2 that's 1/2 or 0.5
so that's really interesting when you're
working with similar triangles or a
right triangle that has that same acute
angle the corresponding sides are going
to be proportional so those trig ratios
are going to be the same so that's the
real magic of trigonometry but let's get
into this first example this
introductory example say for example we
want to find out the sine of angle a the
cosine of angle a and the tangent of
angle a and one thing to notice is that
when we talk about angles we use capital
letters whereas when we talk about the
sides across from the angles we use use
a lowercase letter so this would be like
side a like a lowercase a so what
exactly is a sine of angle a well the
way I like to explain this is pretend
like you're standing at that particular
angle that you're working with that's
your perspective so if you say hmm
sine is the opposite divided by the
hypotenuse so opposite means across
that's 3 divided by the hypotenuse
that's one across from the right angle
that's 5 so the sine of angle a is 3/5
how about the cosine of angle a well
cosine we know is cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse see the cot so adjacent
means next to that's going to be 4
divided by the hypotenuse which is
across from the right angle 5 now some
students go a little bit off the track
here where they'll say well adjacent
isn't that this one here isn't five
adjacent adjacent in everyday language
means next year
right but this one the five is always
going to be the hypotenuse that's always
the one across from the right angle so a
Jason's going to be the other side
that's next to this angle a now with
tangent of angle a we're doing Toa so
that's opposite over adjacent that's
going to be opposite which is 3 divided
by adjacent which is 4 now another thing
that students sometimes like to do is as
soon as they get the triangle and
they're working with angle AEB they'll
just label opposite you know right
opposite here adjacent the right
adjacent here hypotenuse hypotenuse and
then they can just use your their
sohcahtoa
you know acronym to help them with those
ratios let's switch over to sine of
angle B now so here what we're doing is
we're no longer over here okay we're
standing at angle B right this angle and
that's our perspective so we say what's
the sine in angle B well that's gonna be
opposite okay the one that's across
that's 4 divided by the hypotenuse
that's 1 that's across the Wrangell 5
how about the cosign of angle B well
cosine is adjacent that's 3 over the
hypotenuse that's across from the right
angle 5 and what about the tangent of
angle B so tangent is opposite that's 4
over adjacent that's the one next to
here which is 3 again we don't want to
use the 5 that's the hypotenuse so again
if you can just remember Soh kah Toa and
just remember it's always a second
divided by the third you'll have those
trigonometric ratios so now let's get
into some other example problems where
you're given the angle and you want to
find the missing side so everything that
we've been working on in this lesson so
far this is right triangle trigonometry
meaning that you have a triangle with a
90 degree angle there's other problems
that you can do not involving a right
triangle where we get into the law of
sines the law of cosines which is
different from just our regular sine and
cosine for number one though we want to
solve for this missing side here this X
okay so what you want to do is you want
to position yourself at the angle right
and then you say well what trig ratio
sine cosine or tangent ties together
this 23 degree angle this opposite side
floor and this hypotenuse acts and you
only
I have one unknown one variable if you
have more than one unknown more than one
variable you're not gonna be able to
solve this so in this case we have let's
see opposite and hypotenuse Oh opposite
hypotenuse that's sine so we say the
sine of 23 degrees equals the opposite
side which is 4 divided by the
hypotenuse X now what you can do is you
can think of this as sine of 23 divided
by 1 and now we have is a ratio equal to
ratio or fraction equal to a fraction
this forms a proportion and we can use
the properties of proportions to solve
so one way to do this is you can
interchange these on the diagonal I
could put X here and sign a 23 here X
divided by 1 is just X and we've got the
variable by itself but what I find is a
lot of students they just like to use
that cross product property they like to
just cross multiply so x times the sine
of 23 equals 4 times 1 which is 4 then
to get X by itself we're just going to
divide both sides by the sine of 23 to
keep the equation balanced and we have X
by itself so now we're gonna go to the
calculator and when you do these
problems you want to make sure you go to
your mode and make sure that you're in
degrees because you can see this angles
in degrees so now we're gonna go 4
divided by the sine of 23 degrees which
comes out to I'm just gonna round to the
tenths this is about ten point two and
that's the length of this side right
here the hypotenuse and you got it so
let's go to another example see if we
can do this one number two so number two
we're trying to solve for this missing
side here why we have to ask ourselves
what trig ratio sine cosine or tangent
ties together this angle this side and
this side
well again remember you want to position
yourself at the angle you want to
pretend like you're standing at the 16
degree angle and then you say this is
the adjacent side because here next to
this one across from the right angle is
the hypotenuse so adjacent and
hypotenuse okay that looks like Chi
which is cosine so we're going to say
the cosine of the angle cosine of 16
degrees equals the adjacent side divided
by the hypotenuse now all we have to do
to solve is we want to get Y by itself
so instead of dividing by 15
we're just going to multiply both sides
by 15 so we have 15 times the cosine of
16 degrees which comes out to 14 point
four and you've got that missing side
one last example working with these side
links what trig function do you think
ties together this angle this side and
this side is it sine cosine or tangent
well again let's position ourselves at
the angle
we've got opposite and adjacent so okay
opposite adjacent that's Toa so this is
the tangent so we have the tangent of 32
degrees equals the opposite side seven
divided by the adjacent side Z and then
again we can use that property of
proportions where you can switch these
on the diagonal or we can just do the
cross product property we'll just cross
multiply so Z times the tangent of 32
degrees equals so now we're just going
to divide by the tangent of 32 to both
sides of the equation and now we have Z
equals seven divided by the tangent of
32 degrees which comes out to 11.2 and
you found the missing side so the next
thing we want to do is we want to talk
about how do you solve for when you
don't know the angle but you know the
side lengths and that's where the sine
inverse cosine inverse sin tangent
inverse come into play okay number four
we're looking for this missing angle axe
so we want to do is say my D you want to
position yourself at the angle and you
say what trig ratio ties together the
opposite side and the adjacent side from
this angle
well opposite adjacent we know that's
Toa so we're going to say the tangent of
x degrees equals the opposite side which
is three divided by the adjacent side
which is eight now the thing is we want
to get this angle by itself but we have
tangent of X how do we get rid of this
tangent that's where the sine inverse
cosine inverse and tangent inverse come
into play so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the tangent inverse
of the left side we're going to take the
tangent inverse of the right side keep
this balanced these are inverses they
undo one another and we get the angle
now by itself so X is equal to the
tangent inverse
of three ovaries we're gonna go to the
calculator again now and you'll probably
notice right above the sine cosine
tangent you see these sign and you've
got that minus one or cosine minus one
or tangent minus 1 that means the
inverse so you want to press that second
key I'm on a ti-84 here so second tan
inverse of 3/8 and that comes out to
about 20 point six degrees so here we
solve for the angle how about for number
five same idea we're trying to solve for
angle Y now we position ourselves at the
angle and we say what trig ratio ties
together opposite and hypotenuse so that
one's going to be us and hypotenuse
that's so or sine so we say the sine of
angle y equals opposite 4 over
hypotenuse which is 10 now again to get
the angle Y by itself we have to get rid
of the sine here we want to do the
inverse we're going to take the sine
inverse of the left side and the sine
inverse of the right side so we get Y by
itself now and we're going to go to our
calculator sine inverse of 4 divided by
10 which comes out to an angle of
twenty-three point six degrees last one
see if you can do this on your own and
after this we're going to do some
problems involving angle of elevation
and angle depression so more like word
type problems or story problems so what
do you think is this one going to be
sine cosine or tangent well let's see we
position ourselves at the angle we've
got the adjacent side and the one across
to the right angle which is the
hypotenuse so adjacent and hypotenuse
that's cosine so we've got cosine of
angle Z equals adjacent which is 14 over
hypotenuse which is 15 we want to get
angle Z by itself so we're going to take
the cosine inverse of both sides keep it
balanced right so now we have angle Z by
itself and going to the calculator
cosine inverse of 14 over 15 that's a
twenty one point zero degrees is that
angle before we do number seven and
number eight these application problems
with angle elevation angle depression if
you're new to the channel we're
meeting for the first time my name is
Mario of Mario's math tutoring and I'm a
full time master I work with students
every day and what I try to do is take
what I learn working with students about
what helps them to grasp these concepts
the easiest and the quickest and I
incorporated into these videos so that
you can benefit from my math tutoring as
well so if that sounds like something
that you're interested in
check out more math videos on my Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel let's
jump into number seven though what I did
is I've already taken the liberty of
drawing this out for us just to kind of
save space and save time but say for
example you're trying to find the height
of a tree and my drawings not perfect
here the trees a little bit crooked but
imagine this tree is a vertical straight
up and down and you walk back from the
base of the tree a hundred feet you get
out your protractor and you say hey that
angle of elevation to the top of the
tree is 62 degrees how can we figure out
how tall that tree is without actually
having to climb up the tree and measure
it with a you know measuring tape right
well the first thing I want to talk
about though is you know angle of
elevation when you think of elevation
it's like you're elevating your you're
looking up that's the angle that we're
talking about right there
whereas angle depression you're looking
down from the horizontal okay so for
example there was a bird up here and the
bird was looking down at you
that would be your angle depression
right there not this angle but the one
down from the horizontal this is an
angle of elevation up from the
horizontal and if you remember from
geometry these are actually alternate
interior angles and they're congruent so
if this is 62 this is 62 so that's
something to kind of be aware of but
here we're trying to figure out the
height this is the opposite side this is
the adjacent side so which one's
opposite and adjacent that's Toa
or tangent so we say the tangent of 62
degrees equals H which is opposite over
adjacent which is a hundred all we have
to do now is multiply both sides by a
hundred and we've got it let's see what
that comes out to see how tall this tree
is a hundred times the tangent of
sixty-two degrees a lot of times
students will say you know Mario you
know when are we ever going to use this
and you know trigonometry is really very
useful so you can see we didn't have to
climb that tree we could just stand on
the ground and we could get a pretty
good estimate of
how tall that tree is 188 0.1 feet okay
so let's look at number eight now this
one is a little bit different we're
flying a kite and we let out all the
string that we have and we know it's a
300 foot roll of string we measure that
angle of elevation right up from the
horizontal we say that's a 70 degree
angle okay but we want to know how high
is the kite actually above the ground
straight down okay well of course we
can't you know jump up here and put a
measuring tape and measure that right so
here's where we're using our triangles
our trigonometry right so what trig
function do you think ties together this
angle this side which is opposite this
side which is hypotenuse hmm opps and
hypotenuse that's so or sine so we're
going to say the sine of 70 degrees
equals the opposite which is H over the
hypotenuse which is 300 now all we have
to do is multiply both sides by 300 to
keep it balanced get that H by itself
and go to our calculator 300 sine of 70
degrees is 280 I'm just gonna round
about 282 feet above the ground if you
like my teaching style and you want to
learn more about trigonometry follow me
over to that video right there where we
dive into how to solve right triangles
meaning you're finding all the angles
all the sines it's usually the next step
when you're learning about trigonometry
so I'll see over in that video